[Music]
play is the highest form of research
einstein allegedly said today play also
happens in video games
and teachers use them in class or for
homework for this video we teamed up
with the folks at g2a
the world's largest marketplace for
games to learn about the three
dimensions of game design
four things games can potentially teach
us and five video games that are great
for learning
one of which is played at harvard
business school
first the three dimensions of video game
design
games typically range from simple to
complex
they can be played in a single or
multiplayer mode
and can be played collaboratively or
competitively
we can divide games along the spectrum
of simple to complex
and non-social to social simple single
player games include puzzles and jump
and run games like super mario
complex non-social games include the
shooters like far cry
or simulations like simcity then there
are simple multiplayer games
like guitar hero or need for speed and
games that are complex
and social such as halo minecraft or
among us
games can be competitive cooperative or
both
complex multiplayer games are usually
most effective
for learning
now onto the four things games can teach
us
video games can increase our cognitive
abilities boost our motivation
make us aware of our emotions and
strengthen our social skills
games can increase cognition by
strengthening particular areas of our
brain
one meta-analysis showed that video
games effectively teach mental rotation
abilities
and that such learning can be
transferred to the real world
logic and mathematical thinking can also
be effectively learned through specific
video games
shooter games for example often train
our understanding of relations among
objects in space
better than regular high school programs
games can boost our motivation and warm
us up for learning
feedback loops that adjust to one's
abilities keep players within what
vygotsky called
the zone of proximal development and as
we learn that we advance through the
process of trying
failing and doing we can develop a
growth mindset
some of the confidence we gain through
games can be transferred to other
aspects of life
there are emotional benefits and some
studies report a causal relationship
between playing video games and improved
mood this makes sense
being that according to uses and
gratification theory
most of us seek diverse forms of media
to manage our mental state
putting the books aside for a short game
break can therefore enhance our
emotional state
one study reported that gamers often
experience high levels of stress
and as a result learn to manage their
emotions
there can be social benefits as we form
new relationships
in some games we need to learn who to
trust how to communicate
and when to take the lead video games
that are designed to reward cooperation
promote pro-social skills particularly
well
one longitudinal study found that
children who played more pro-social
games at the beginning of the school
year
were more likely to exhibit helpful
behaviors later on in the year
finally let's look at five games that
deliver powerful learning experiences
remission is a video game that teaches
sick children how to deal with cancer
in the game the children control a
nanobot that shoots cancer cells and
manages the side effects of the
treatment
a randomized control trial showed that
children who played remission
significantly increased adherence to the
treatment protocol and cancer-related
knowledge
the game has since helped hundreds of
thousands of young patients
the game minecraft promotes creativity
collaboration
and problem solving through trial and
error players build their own world and
alongside
apply math and learn about shapes and
geometry
some do electrical engineering and build
machines that run
in the virtual world and others explore
human history
its education edition gives teachers
special control
and access to a wide catalog of lessons
in democracy players get to know the
challenges of being a politician
they learn the basics of economics and
discover how policies affect real people
they have to deal with difficult issues
like immigration
and unemployment and then still try to
win the majority support in the next
election
the app brain quake allows students to
learn math in a playful way
and without using symbolic language
controlled experiments showed improved
math scores by 20
when third graders play the game for
just 10 minutes per day
three days a week for a month the game
was developed with the help of the
popular math teacher
keith devlin its education edition
allows teachers to monitor students
progress
and creativity
the so-called harvard root beer game is
a team-based business simulation
in which players manage a factory a
distributor a wholesaler
or a retailer of root beer at the
beginning of the game
the root beer isn't popular but then it
becomes a big hit
each player now needs to decide what to
do as they examine inventory
anticipate demand and right orders the
game is played at top business schools
because it teaches the importance of
open communication
and teamwork what about you
what do you think about the up and down
sides of playing video games for
learning
and have you ever learned something in a
video game that was later useful in real
life
if you want to learn more about the
topic the people at g2a have developed a
free online course especially designed
for teachers
just check it out at g2a.com academy
or read the description below for more
details
[Music]
sprouts videos are published under the
creative commons license
that means our videos are free and
anyone can download
edit and play them for personal use and
public schools
governments and non-profit organizations
can also use them for training
online courses or designing new
curriculums
to help us stay independent and support
our work you can join our patrons and
contribute
just visit patreon.com sprouts
even one dollar can make a difference